like Kevin Bacon in Footloose the real
Footloose not the lame remake Just Dance
is always finding new ways to bring
people together with dance and in that
spirit the team is introducing a brand
new way to break out of your living room
and further deliver on the promise that
everyone and anyone can dance including
a freakishly tall klutzy yet slightly
masculine girl like me here to tell us
more is just dances executive producer
mr. Jason Altman
hi everyone I'm here to introduce Just
Dance now a completely new way to play
the game with anyone anywhere and at any
time all you need is a smartphone and an
Internet connected big screen like a
tablet a PC or a smart TV it doesn't
matter what kind of smartphone you have
or even if you're all in different
connections Wi-Fi 3G 4G everyone will be
in sync playing together in real time
this isn't just a breakthrough for Just
Dance this is a breakthrough in latency
free multi device online gaming let me
show you how it works I've downloaded
the free app to my phone on my connected
big screen I go to Just Dance Now calm
it detects my smartphone lets me join
the dance room and we're playing just
dance as usual when I play just dance I
follow the dancer on screen and use a
controller to dance only now the
controller is my phone Just Dance has
always been about a small group of
players having fun together at a living
room or at a party the magic of Just
Dance now is that there's no limit to
the number of people who can play from
four people to 20 people at a birthday
party to the 2,000 people in this
auditorium to 20,000 people at a stadium
concert anyone with a smartphone you can
see that big screen can join the game
bringing us one step closer connecting
the world through dance let's play
ah
it's a fighter
was a part of
the applause our little
yeah
alright let's find out into our winner
is highest score in the room is Alberta
give it up for Alberta everybody that
was awesome it was incredibly and I
think that an honorable mention goes to
Jason oh it was a g4 effort yeah thank
you everybody